völlig erschöpft und übernächtigt geht
es ins finale am fünften und letzten tag
der belastungs übung müssen die
soldatinnen und soldaten noch mal alles
geben
mit den letzten energiereserven geht es
zurück in die kaserne in enns wer jetzt
aufgrund einer verletzung oder
überanstrengung ausschaltet muss alles
noch einmal machen
es ist sechs uhr früh ohne schlaf
marschierten die gruppen durch die nacht
erst das hindernis ist ein fluss der mit
hilfe eines einstiegs bewältigt werden
muss und zwar aus vielleicht anstrengend
man ist mir die kamera entstehen für die
gruppe 2 12 läuft das auch zeitlich gut
doch plötzlich lag zugführer peitler
über starke schmerzen im knie schulen
fällt von einer überbelastung sie nicht
mit so dass jetzt den marstall und
fertig irgendwer
nun soll proporz eine geben der war
schon kurz erfordert sich abgemeldet
hatte die sachen alle abgeben die
gruppen gerät sind und wollte schnell
gehen aber da man den letzten momenten
rom stimmt und das bis jetzt hatten wir
doch ein bisschen schluss zu stellen
sichtlich erschöpft erreicht auch die
gruppe 111 den sei stieg trotz des
harten marsches durch die regnerische
nacht ist die gruppe noch vollständig
alles andere als selbstverständlich
denn ausfälle gab es diese nacht mehrere
die letzte nacht war geprägt durch den
marsch hierher bzw weiter an die donau
es kam sehr schwer und dazu das sehr
starker nebel war was das orientieren
erschwert hat zwei gruppen haben dabei
noch gröbere fehler gemacht und einen
zusätzlichen marschweg in kauf genommen
und eine zeit einbuße von zwei bis drei
stunden gehabt wir halten jetzt
insgesamt bei 15 ausfällen wie gesagt 10
vom beginn der woche bis gestern und
fünf weitere sind in den frühen
morgenstunden dazugekommen heute von
mitternacht weg bis
so biss wieder dämmerung kommen ist
sechs uhr
sowas nochmal richtig schlimm weil man
ist mir hunger und für sw und kleinster
w man geht einfach durch das war schon
anstrengend ja weiter hat heute zum
mikrofon
drei meter sicht ca war er nicht nur
vorteile
nächste station gepäcks kontrolle wer
etwas vermisst ist schuld dass die ganze
gruppe einen umweg gehen muss und da ist
es auch schon passiert wachtmeister
ladner sucht vergebens nach einem hart
wir sind ein haar in villingen kommen
verloren und nicht wiedergefunden haben
meldet hatte man extra für danach
bekommen und jetzt muss die ganze gruppe
an
nicht irgendwas die gruppe wird mit
einem umweg von ca 5 km bestraft für die
ohnehin angeschlagene gruppe eine
zusätzliche belastungsprobe
doch eins nach dem anderen
mit pionier boten soll erstmal die donau
überquert werden
eigentlich eine erholende abwechslung zu
marschieren
wäre da nicht das rudern und die starke
strömung
zeitgleich nähert sich auch schon gruppe
1 11 der donau
auch hier wird erst noch das gepäck auf
vollständigkeit überprüft
erleichterung in der gruppe nichts fehlt
und somit keine strafrunde
ich bin generell sehr zufrieden mit
meiner klasse nur zwei ausfälle kopte
waren ganz an den anfang am ersten tag
ja die leistungsfähige sehr gut und das
haus zu kommen ist es deshalb nun ist er
wie wohl auch vollzähligen das ist will
ich finde da jetzt auch ein bisschen
stolz ich bin eigentlich stolz auf meine
gaswerken volle kanne
nach 20 minuten hardcore boden gegen die
strömung erreicht gruppe 2 12 das andere
ufer
doch viel zeit zum ausruhen gibt es
nicht vor allem da die mannschaft eine
fünf kilometer lange strafrunde
marschieren muss die knieverletzung beim
zugführer peitler erschwert das ganze
noch jetzt kommt es auf den zusammenhalt
in der gruppe an
mit eisernen willen marschiert aigner
weiter
endlich es ist geschafft nach fünf tagen
dauer belastung über 100 kilometer
fahrstrecke schwierigen hindernissen und
dauerregen erreicht gruppe 1 11 die
kaserne in enns früher als erhofft weil
sie keinen umweg gehen musste doch
freudensprünge und jubel gibt es nicht
wie in trance und zu erschöpft sind die
soldatinnen und soldaten
b
auch gruppe 2 12 zählt nun offiziell zu
den erfolgreichen absolventen der
belastungs übung und stellt sich der
letzten schwierigen aufgabe dem
abschluss
alles
die traditionelle
schon gewusst dass es schwierig wird
aber wir werden nicht sagen können was
da jetzt wirklich offenbar sie ja also
ich bin schon stolz dass ich jetzt
gehabt dass die ganze gruppen
durchkommen ist seltsam wieder locken
natürlich ist besondere ausstellung d
brille zu bestehen ist nicht einfach
dass er wirklich sehr lang ist
eigentlich und man am anfang mit dem
rechner etwas dafür probleme auftreten
können
natürlich freut man sich auf den
abschluss der übung vor allem dann
reinkommt maradona und erstattung von
den sieg und was sind jetzt die letzten
kilometer was man geht und danach ins
backend von bruckner und ich einfach
einmal muss man kann schrieb mir gern zu
viel freiheit muss sich ändern
die letzten kilometer kann auf jeden
fall aufpassen sicher nicht einfach aber
machbar
wir gehen jetzt schon glücklich die
letzten kilometer waren sehr zeit und
jetzt bin ich froh dass es endlich
vorbei ist und jetzt sind sie stolz auf
sich
nach dieser super leistung ich hab mich
stolz auf die welt noch einige
ausgefallen
und schon gekämpft zum schluss aber das
ist einfach ist und ich bin echt stolz
auf mich